so this past weekend Jarvis he's a faze
clan member and a pretty popular YouTube
content creator announced in an
emotional video that he was banned for
life from fortnight for cheating aimbot
Eng specifically now this isn't your
average tale of eSports cheating either
Jarvis didn't covertly install aim
assist software to help him out in
online qualifiers or to win a big pot on
land
Jarvis did it for the views
[Music]
all right so Jarvis kay phase Jarvis for
most of us is at this point never
playing for the world's most popular
video game ever a game he is never
playing what made him a YouTube star
again this guy is 17 years old and he
has 2 million YouTube subscribers most
of them off the back of fortnight
content yes he has a couple Cod videos
from like four years ago and he did some
stunts and pranks and things like that
but essentially this guy is a fortnight
content creator the TLDR here is that
Jarvis uploaded a video where he used
some kind of aim assist software plus a
little wall hacks that's embodying for
all you true gamers out there an epic
said according to Jarvis himself this
means that he was banned for life from
playing fortnight he dropped this news
in a very emotional video over the
weekend
I'm truly I so sorry epic I know I have
to take accountability for my actions
and you know I'm gonna I'm gonna do my
best to accept any punishment or light
comes my way whatever happens I'm not
trying to find like a quick road out but
like being banned forever it's just I
can't get him up a life time that is it
oh I just did I know I didn't expect now
the video where he uses the aimbot was
deleted from his channel but obviously
it's still available on the internet so
what's the deal well I watched it and
basically Jarvis says he do ode with
some random dude who told him he could
get him a Miss his software and Jarvis
was like yeah sure why not no idea if
the story's authentic doesn't really
matter anyways Jarvis at this point says
that he has heard that if you make a new
account install a BOTS software and use
it right away that you're an easy target
for epic banning you so what he says he
does is he plays a few games where it's
not activated to fool the fortnight
police or whatever but when you make a
new account and user ain't vote you get
banned really easily because your aim so
good in your first game so we're just
gonna play a game or two with our aim
box so the like the fortnight
the porn I please I don't know who is
watching me don't catch me I'm saying
I'm not trying to get banned instantly
he uses an alt account he doesn't use
his main PC and like I said he doesn't
even turn on the aim-assist
until later even drops a little helpful
PSA about how all you kids at home
should never use an aimbot before we
kill anyone I really just want to say
never use a bow change never ever use a
bow and your whole life never do it
you're gonna get banned I'm a hundred
percent gonna get banned on this account
so never ever do it guys I I just can't
stress it enough it's not good like
you're not gonna get better at the game
for anybody's know how it works the rest
of the video is basically just Jarvis
dunking on a bunch of poor fools in
soloqueue oh look on to someone else I'm
so good at this video game what I don't
understand is how he uploaded this video
and it's like a shock that he was
permanently banned serious question did
anyone at faze clan actually vet this
thing before it went online I mean
people knew about this before it went up
phase K who's his brother was in the
video using the aimbot with Jarvis
somebody edited this video somebody made
the thumbnail somebody uploaded it to
YouTube and nowhere along this whole
process did someone say hold up guys I
think we might get [ __ ] up if we do
this I mean it's pretty clear from the
video that Jarvis understood at least
some of the consequences of what he was
doing at the end of the day he cheated
knowingly in a premeditated manner for
content and hey look it's pretty good
content the deagle is not man I'm
willing to believe there was a scene
where Jarvis and his brother were in
their house and they were like oh my god
dude what if I get an a bot and we turn
it on and we [ __ ] with some people in
soloqueue it's gonna be a sick video and
we're gonna do like 20 million views I
could see that conversation happening
and look the video is funny for you for
me for Jarvis maybe not for the other 99
people in the server but it's funny the
question and the debate now that it's
all over is does the punishment fit the
crime does Jarvis deserve to be perma
banned now earlier this year two dudes
Ziff and Ronaldo cheated in fortnight
World Cup qualifiers they were given 14
day bans and then they qualified for the
World Cup
anyway now these two guys didn't use
aimbots or walls or whatever they
basically colluded with other players to
get easy kills and easy points still
they made it to a thirty million dollar
tournament despite being convicted
cheaters in the same season 490 sports
man so epic had this cheating problem
they banned these two dudes for 14 days
and it totally backfired you got to
imagine after that Fiasco that epic is
looking to go hard on cheaters and
Jarvis put himself right in the
crosshairs the other issue to consider
here is that while those two dorks who
are secretly colluding with other
players to get easy kills
what Jarvis did is on a whole new level
anything's right but people who cheat in
the World Cup don't get a perma ban I
mean the people who cheated the World
Cup they teamed right
didn't using a third-party program to
boost their aim or anything like that
look what Jarvis was doing was
celebrating his use of cheating software
he was showing off just how [ __ ] up it
is to use aimbot in soloqueue and
uploading the results for two million
people to see that's 2 million kids who
see this video and start to think it's
cool or funny to troll people who're
just trying to play a fair game it's not
just about the harm that jarvis did in a
couple games of solo Hugh it's about the
harm that he did by uploading that to 2
million people and making it look
appealing to cheat if you ask me that
means that epic had to drop the ban
hammer on this guy now whether or not it
should be permanent well for me that's
up for debate he does seem pretty
remorseful and I'm not gonna lie my
heart kind of goes out to the kid
maybe epoch can cut his sentence down to
six months or even a year let him stew
in it let him reckon with the
consequences of his actions and hurt his
bottom line as a YouTube creator just a
little bit
look he's young he [ __ ] up we've all
been there but maybe killing this kid's
career for life isn't the answer
then again not every
agrees nobody wants to get filled by
name by so you have to treat it very
carefully so what do you think you
having I think that you should be
permanent band just like it's something
for kids to call slightly older people
like slightly that the joke is that
you're not a you're not a little baby
boomer so no one's literally a boomer
right like you're my parents are actual
doors but like Gen Zed is like Zoomers
so it's a way of being like ha ha you're
the new boomer right and the boomer joke
is like if you even betrayed for like a
split second so you're not 100% in
lockstep with what is cool at this very
moment you're a [ __ ] boom
[Music]